we'll stick with this one for the time  being and then we'll give a little recap  yeah this would have been a very  exciting round by the way there's barely  any draws there's a draw between Nielsen  widget and also that drawback between  Eric and uh who was Eric playing  uh Vincent yeah  I think there are six decisive games  this round as far as I mean assuming  Arjun wins but I think it's a fairly  safe assumption because  white countries stop the people costing  them the full Rook  I think that's six out of eight which is  well that's that okay yeah you swipe the  bishop and game over so just let's take  a look at the leading scores three  players on 13. we have noribbeck Abdul  sator of young